hi i'm mackenzie brown today i'll be
breaking down how archery is portrayed
in video games
[Music]
the video games we'll be looking at our
assassin's creed the last of us
crisis the forest stranded deep
thief horizon zero dawn the witcher
far cry and tomb raider let's take a
look at how archery skills are portrayed
in video games
technique crisis 3
[Music]
the angle of the bow is over to the side
what we would call that is
can't the arrow would potentially
go more to the right doesn't really give
you much
it just kind of looks cool same thing in
crime
movies and things like that where
someone will point a gun and they'll aim
it sideways
i don't think that this is very helpful
to aiming
our eyes naturally want to line circle
up a circle
line with line and notice the
differences there i think it's something
to kind of look cool but doesn't
actually
help you shoot any better injured
shoulder
the last of us part two
this video was extremely painful to
watch
if she was shot in her shoulder and
there was only a small amount
penetrating through the back side of her
shoulder
i would actually say to push
the arrow through
[Music]
whenever you pull back out the shape of
the broad head
is going to be more like a shark tooth
so as you're coming out
you're pulling all of that muscle and
tendon that you've already
damaged if i were in that scenario i'd
probably try to find a tree
and push myself against the tree to push
the arrow out that way
[Music]
i probably wouldn't shoot a bow just
because of the range of motion that you
have to have to be able to draw a bow
i think it would be extremely painful to
lift your arm much less pull a bow back
who knows i might do some crazy stuff i
was shot in the shoulder
so running and shooting the last of us
we have a character who is loading the
bow very quickly and making a shot
extremely quickly
the arrows probably aren't being
actually
knocked onto the bow on our equipment we
have these plastic
knocks that are at the end of the arrow
that attach
the actual arrow to the string so that
when we draw back the arrow doesn't fall
off
as an olympic archer there's not really
a need to
load super quick it only takes me about
15 seconds after
i've put an arrow on to fully shoot my
shot
running and shooting at the same time is
not necessarily recommended it would
make it very difficult to arrange
your target and then aim accurately it
would have to be something that you
practice
all the time shooting through water
stranded deep
in this scenario this guy is stranded so
we have to give him a little bit of
leeway there but one thing that would be
very challenging to me would be getting
the shark out of the water and whenever
bowfishing happens
there's a reel that you attach to your
bow
and there's a an attachment for it to go
to the arrow
so when you shoot you have the string
that trails after the arrow
and then you can reel that in for the
fish that you've shot
water displacement is another thing to
think about the fish may be here
when you see it but it's actually here
under the water so you have to aim
off of the fish to be able to shoot it
reaction time
assassins creed origins
i can honestly say that i have never
jumped off a building
and tried to shoot an arrow at the same
time one thing that
this person has to do is to look at
number one how they're falling towards
the ground
number two how the wind is blowing
number three if the person that you're
shooting at is moving
all of those factors factor into
his shot this is realistic not
necessarily that it's realistic to jump
off of a bridge
and shoot somebody but in a way that you
have to be aware of
many different factors that affect your
shot
next let's take a look at arrows
multiple arrows at once
horizon zero dawn
i actually have tried this i have shot
multiple
arrows off of my bow it feels extremely
strange
that string felt like it was going
through molasses
it was just so slow because it had to
push more out of the way
to get back to its stock position where
the guy is shooting three or four
arrows your arrows would not clump
together like that on the bow
your arrows would go in multiple
different directions if you think about
the stored energy in a bow
the more points that you add into it
divides how much energy is going
into those arrows so whenever you add
multiple arrows onto the string
all that energy is going into three
different places versus
its intended one place i don't think
that it would be very helpful
how arrows fly thief
[Music]
we can see how the arrow is actually
spinning
towards the target and this is something
that's very accurate
that's a very small detail that a lot of
people wouldn't necessarily pick up on
i have one of my arrows here and i'm
actually going to show you how it spins
fletching and feather are
interchangeable so it's whatever
stabilization you have on the back end
of your arrow
mine are made of a plastic material
so you have a lot of energy on this part
of the arrow because this is the point
it's got some weight on it so it's
taking the arrow towards the target
but then the back end needs to be
stabilized otherwise there's going to be
more oscillation
left and right versus when you add that
vein on there it's going to be able to
spin which
stabilizes the arrow as it's in flight
[Music]
very accurate depiction here very
accurate to what an arrow actually does
in flight explosive arrows far
cry 4.
[Applause]
this is something that is exciting to
think about as a scenario but it just
is not practical
[Applause]
you're going to create a weaker shaft
a weaker arrow because there's a heavier
fixed point on the end
the energy is going into the back end of
the arrow but not into the front end of
the arrow
a lot of people would say oh well if the
arrow's too heavy just pull it back
further
because the further you pull the bow
back the heavier the bow gets
you would potentially be putting your
ear your face your nose
in the way of being hit by that string
and i can tell you firsthand
by hitting my arm several times over my
career it is not a pleasant feeling
unlimited ammo crisis 3.
their bow reloads arrows seemingly
coming from nowhere these arrows are
just appearing
and going into the bow and ready to
shoot i
wish that this was possible
that would make my life a little bit
easier we
get our arrows in packages of dozens and
they're separate components
if one of the fletchings is bent or cut
because
it's been shot into the target or
somebody else hits it if a knock breaks
i want to be able to swap that out and
have a good fresh arrow to be able to
shoot
i would imagine that there's a limit on
how many arrows he can
actually load into his bow to be able to
shoot multiple times
i have never seen a bow that reloads
automatically but
props to this guy for having one
arrow strength rise of the tomb raider
i would say that an arrow probably would
not withstand
that much of a bend
our arrows do take on a lot of
a beating whenever we shoot them our
arrows are shooting
anywhere from 200 to 300 feet per second
she would have to have more of the
surface that she's shooting into in the
middle of the arrow to even
maybe make this work
just because i think the arrow would
flex so far down that it would snap
especially depending on what kind of
material her arrows are made
out of ours are made out of a aluminum
core with
a carbon fiber on the outside so they're
pretty strong
but i would not trust this with my life
which is what laura is doing in this
video clip deflecting arrows
the witcher 3.
on average at least for my bow we shoot
about 50 pounds
of draw weight and our arrows are moving
about 200 feet per second or 136 miles
per hour
so if you're thinking about a very small
projectile moving at you
at 136 miles per hour you have to have
ninja skills to be able to
deflect an arrow or move out of the way
that was some pretty bad acting
really how to explore other career
options let's see how bows are
represented in video games
sound the last of us
the most that you're gonna hear whenever
an arrow is flying
is like a th kind of sound
it's just the the fletchings are moving
you're not going to hear
that like it's not very loud at all
there's not actually a lot of sound
that our equipment makes it's not um
gonna have many metal pieces on it it's
not gonna have
a lot of moving parts or anything like
that the
type of bow this guy is shooting is
actually probably going to be one of the
quieter bows
that's out there in real life carrying
the bow
tomb raider got it
we have a fire look for the smoke we're
on our way
in this video you see lara croft
carrying her bow
across her back this is my competition
bow i shoot an olympic recurve it's kind
of a small space
like between the string and my bow
it's not a lot of space to get in there
one thing a lot of people don't realize
is the makeup of our strings and the way
they actually work
think of it as like strands of hair
all together so when they're pulled
really tight
it's all one piece but when they're shot
it kind of flares out
what are you doing here because of the
wear and tear that you would see on that
string
it would be broken down pretty quickly
did you get that compound bow far cry
5. if i die
in this clip some of the parts of this
bow are pretty realistic
especially the part of the draw
there is a stability that you see in the
bow
once you draw back and that's something
that's unique to a compound bow
this is my hunting compound what you'll
notice
that's different from some of the other
bows we've seen today are
these wheels on it and we call these
cams
and they have basically like a pulley
system
in them so whenever you draw the bow
back there will be
a break over moment versus a longbow or
traditional bow
where you can keep drawing keep drawing
keep drawing until
pretty much the bow breaks
the one thing that i would critique is
the fact that there's not really a rest
or a place for that arrow to be sitting
on
usually you would have a separate rest
that you would attach to the bow
for it to hold the arrow up versus it
just sitting on the shelf
of the bow the aiming device only has
two pins they usually come with one pin
three pins or five
i know how this is gonna end bow
modifications
the last of us part two
then calling it a rangefinder is
incorrect i would
just call this a site a rangefinder has
a system of
lasers that determines a distance
between you
and a particular target whereas a
site would be just a fixed item on the
bow
that actually helps you aim at different
distances
i also have a problem with the way she
strung the bow
it was almost like she just pulled the
string off of one end of the bow
and just took it off
you have to actually put pressure onto
the bow to get the limb
to move and flex to get that string
off because it's under tension and then
whenever she
strung the bow again she kind of just
pulled the limb down and then put the
string on
which depending on the weight of the bow
is pretty impractical you have to have
like a 15
20 pound bow to be able to do something
like that maneuver for it to actually
work
the last piece of equipment that they
put on
this bow is a grip they claim that this
would help
with decreasing weapon sway
to my knowledge the only way to kind of
change the way your bow moves or doesn't
move would be to add stabilizers
a grip is just to fit your hand because
everybody's hands are different
when you look at my bow that i compete
with i have these bars
on my bow that hang off that help
balance the bow
yeah this'll do let's talk about targets
moving target far cry 3
the first thing that jumps out at me is
just the delayed reaction
of the shot you hear the shot hit and
then the guy goes
and it's just like so delayed it cracks
me up something that you would look at
in this scenario would be the movement
of the truck the movement of the people
in the truck
you also have to take into account the
sunshine versus
wind and direction and all of that stuff
leading the target a little bit is very
helpful we kind of
are just mitigating variables whenever
we're shooting
at any type of target cabela's big game
hunter
pro hunts
i actually would kind of disagree
because
the person is shooting center mass and
then they're shooting lower than the
sternum so the sternum is going to be a
pretty
solid bone to shoot against
you see on the end of the arrow has a
broad head
these blades don't move the razor sharp
and pretty much stay that way
but whenever you shoot it stays open
like that
i think that's pretty accurate to what
happens in real life
that was close but still off the mark
making an
arrow the forest in this video i'm going
to quickly show you how to craft the bow
and arrow in the forest
add the cloth add the rope and then add
your stick
craft it together and you now have your
bow some of the bare bones of this is
true
you do need a stick you do need
rope or some sort of string granted this
is a video game
but the sticky hat had a lot of knots
and burrs on it and it also had quite a
few v's off
for like twigs and stuff like that and
you now have your bow
i would try to find all one contiguous
piece building the bow you need some
cloth
and just crack open pretty much any
suitcase i don't think that you need
cloth to be able to make a bow to make
your arrows you're gonna need some
feathers which are right up there in
your backpack so you add them to your
craft thing
and get the stick and you can now craft
your
arrows as far as the execution or the
making of the arrows
i would say trying to find straighter
sticks and then kind of whittling those
down into straight
cylinders versus something that's
a little bit more crooked and all of
that's just for accuracy
hidden target wii sports resort
i've actually shot some fruit before it
makes your arrows very sticky and it's
not fun to clean up
it's not going to stick out like this
one it's going to go straight through
that watermelon i would recommend
not shooting anything that you can't
comfortably aim on
or see plus why would you want to shoot
a watermelon when you can shoot
a target
i've had several people asked me
to shoot an apple off of their head even
strangers like
in the airport even though i'm very
confident in the way i shoot i still
would i just wouldn't take that risk
there wouldn't be enough fun
involved there would just be a whole lot
of fear
unbelievable
i think it's very interesting to see all
parts of archery and how it's
shown in different mediums a couple of
the
videos had really good arrow flight in
them attention to detail
was really there i really enjoyed my
experience today
and hopefully helped you learn a little
bit about my sport
[Music]